well for months now eight news now has
been telling you stories of the
coronavirus pandemic
thanks for joining us here at six i'm
denise feldas and i'm brian loftis the
big question for so many where is covid
coming from
and are there hot spots in certain areas
the i-team's david charns continues his
report tonight
with answers to those questions and he's
joining us live from bonanza and lamb
over the east side of the valley
david well brian this is the center of
sunrise manor no part of the valley has
seen more cases of cobit 19 than where
we are right now tonight
specifically the zip code 89110
take a look at this map here the darker
the color
the more cases you can see where you
live on that map
and the flashing zip code where we are
is 89110 on the east side
this neighborhood is full of people who
are the backbone of our economy
and there have been more infections here
than anywhere else
the roots of the las vegas economy run
deep here on the east side
in the shadow of frenchman mountain the
diverse working class neighborhood of
sunrise manor has
seemingly hid in the darkness more
people have been diagnosed with covet 19
and 89110
than anywhere else in clark county these
are folks who
have not had the luxury of having to
work remotely and
sometimes they don't even have access to
paid sick leave
councilwoman olivia diaz represents this
area for the city
commission chair marilyn kirkpatrick for
the county because they do still have to
get up and go to work every single day
and they are still trying to provide for
their families that family unit
is important in these 11 square miles
where nearly two thirds of the
population is hispanic
thousands of adults live with both their
parents and their children
three generations all in one home you
have
young folks still working and then you
have older folks still staying at home
watching the younger ones
vanessa vasquez lives here with her four
children and husband
she says they all got and survived kovit
she had to leave her job due to the
pandemic and just days before we talked
to her here in this park
her sister died the family has no money
to bury her
she says many in the latino community
don't have papers or insurance
we're hopeless without insurance and we
have to pay out of pocket she tells me
how can we pay out of pocket with no
money and no job
sunrise is in its name but in the days
of the pandemic
coronavirus seemed to eclipse this part
of town
health leaders soon realized testing
levels in 89110 didn't match
other more affluent neighborhoods what
we found early on is
many people didn't want to go get tested
because they were afraid they were going
to have to take time off
work and then what did that look like to
ease that problem
diaz and kirkpatrick worked to bring in
more manpower
test kits and information in spanish
about the virus
that was no small task it took the
entire village and the entire community
banding together
the i-team filed a public records
request with the southern nevada health
district eventually leading to data for
possible places of exposure
we asked for specific locations instead
getting categories
the health district describing the top
category other
as people's homes family gatherings and
other social events
the family gatherings piece has been i
think the hardest
us being a culture that likes to get
together with family
but the data isn't perfect it can take
up to two weeks for symptoms to appear
and some categories bleed into one
another in addition to gatherings you
could guess the other top categories
food establishments hotels medical
facilities
work and grocery stores more than 11
thousand have gotten sick here
some those who had to go to work those
who hosted their families
have died the fight though is not over
it's heart wrenching to hear from all
the people who have lost
potentially both of their parents or
their grandparents
a loved one a spouse a daughter a son
now those lives are part of the record
here as 89110 moves
forward as this pandemic spotlights yet
another side
of inequality so it's really highlighted
what this community has been suffering
through for a long time
now we know how to get them those
resources and there's a lot of folks
around the valley that
now understand what that looks like
and that work now continues with vaccine
equity
but as we see cases drop across the
valley
they're still rising here in 89110 with
more than 130 cases
reported here in just the past seven
days once again
leading the valley in new cases we're
live tonight at bonanza and lamb i'm
david charns 8 news now
david thanks for that tonight and right
now on 8newsnow.com and also inside of
our app you can see where your zip code
stacks up in terms of the number of
copic cases
plus you can also take a look at the
data that the i-team requested
for where people across the valley may
have been exposed to the virus
our app is free and it's in your app
store